in the previous video you saw the
logistic regression model to train the
parameters W and B of your logistic
regression model you need to define a
cost function let's take a look at a
cost function you can use to Train
logistic regression to recap this is
what we had defined from the previous
slide so you output Y hat is sigmoid of
W transpose X plus B where sigmoid of z
is as defined here so to learn
parameters for your model you're given a
training set of M training examples and
it seems natural that you want to find
parameters W and B so that at least on
the training set the outputs you have
the predictions you have on the training
set we're going to write this Y hat I
that that would be close to the ground
truth labels Y either you got in the
training set so to fill in a little bit
more detail for the equation on top we
have said that Y has as defined at the
top for a training example X and of
course for each training example we're
using these super scripts with round
brackets with parentheses to index into
different training examples your
prediction on training example I which
is y hat I is going to be obtained by
taking the sigmoid function and applying
it to W transpose X I the input for the
training example plus B and you can also
define Z I as follows where Zi is equal
to you know W transpose X I plus B so
throughout this course we're going to
use this notational convention that the
superscript parentheses I refers to data
via X or Y or Z or something else
associated with the i'f training example
associated with the i'f example okay
that's what the superscript I in
parenthesis means now let's see what
loss function or an error function we
can use to measure how well our
algorithm is doing one thing you could
do is define the loss when your
algorithm outputs Y hat and the true
label is y to be maybe the squared error
or one hover square
it turns out that you could do this but
in logistic regression people don't
usually do this because when you come to
learn the parameters you find that the
optimization problem which we'll talk
about later becomes non convex so you
end up with ostentation problem it would
not talk local optima so gradient
descent may not find a global optimum if
you didn't understand the last couple of
comments don't worry about it we'll get
to it in the later video but the
intuition to take away is that this
function L called the loss function is a
function we need to define to measure
how good our output Y hat is when the
true label is y and squared error seems
like it might be a reasonable choice
except that it makes gradient descent
not work well so in logistic regression
we will actually define a different loss
function that plays a similar role as
squared error that will give us an
optimization problem that is convex and
so will see in a later video becomes
much easier to optimize so what we use
in logistic regression is actually the
following loss function which ones with
my rent out here is negative y log y hat
plus 1 minus y log 1 minus y hat here's
some intuition for why this loss
function exists keep in mind that if
we're using squared error then you want
this squared error to be as small as
possible and with this logistic
regression loss function we'll also want
this to be as small as possible to
understand why this makes sense let's
look at the two cases in the first case
let's say Y is equal to 1 then the loss
function Y has comma Y is just the
stress term right under the negative
sign so it's negative log Y hat if y is
equal to 1 because if y equals 1 then
the second term 1 minus y is equal to 0
so this says if y equals 1 you want
negative Y hat to be as big as possible
so that means you want
log y hat to be large to be as big as
possible and that means you want y hat
to be large but because y hat is you
know the sigmoid function it can never
be bigger than one so this is saying
that if Y is equal to one you once Y has
to be as big as possible but it can't
ever be bigger than one so saying you
want Y hat to be close to one as well
the other case is if y equals zero if y
equals zero then this first term in the
loss function is equal to zero because y
0 and in the second term defines the
loss function so the loss becomes
negative log 1 minus y hat and so if is
a learning procedure you try to make the
last function small what this means is
that you want log 1 minus y hat to be
large and because it's a negative sign
there and then through a similar piece
of reasoning you can conclude that this
loss function is trying to make y hat as
small as possible and again because Y
hat has to be between 0 & 1 this is
saying that if Y is equal to 0 then your
loss function will push the parameters
so make Y hat as close to zero as
possible now there are a lot of
functions with roughly this effect that
if Y is equal to 1 you try to make Y hat
knowledge and Y is equal to 0 or try to
make Y hat small we just gave here in
green a somewhat informal justification
for this particular loss function will
provide an optional video later to give
a more formal justification for Y in
logistic regression we like to use the
loss function with this particular form
finally the loss function was defined
with respect to a single training
example it measures how well you're
doing on a single training example are
now going to define something called the
cost function which measures how are you
doing on the entire training set so the
cost function J which is applied to your
parameter W NP is going to be the
average ly 1 over m of the sum
of the last function applied to each of
the training examples in turn when here
Y has is of course the prediction output
by your logistic regression algorithm
using you know a particular set of
parameters W and B and so just to expand
this out this is equal to negative 1
over m sum from I equals 1 through m of
the definition of the last function
above so this is why I log Y hat I plus
1 minus y I log 1 minus y hat I because
it can put square brackets here so the
minus sign goes outside everything else
so the terminology I'm going to use is
that the loss function is applied to
just a single training example like so
and the cost function is the cost of
your parameters so in training your
logistic regression model we're going to
try to find parameters W and B that
minimize the overall cost function J
written at the bottom so you've just
seen the set up for the logistic
regression algorithm the loss function
for a training example and the overall
cost function for the parameters of your
algorithm it turns out that logistic
regression can be viewed as a very very
small neural network in the next video
we'll go over that so you can start
gaining intuition about what neural
networks do so that let's go on to the
next video about how to view logistic
regression as a very small neural
network